I like to break down
the DNA of a song,
to show you where it came from.
In the case of "Nice
for What", Drake
sampling Lauryn Hill, when
Lauryn Hill is sampling
Wu-Tang Clan, which is Gladys
Knight covering a Barbra
Streisand song.
It's a meta rabbit hole.
Sometimes, you got to
let people in on the fun,
and there's nothing more
fun than the discovery of,
"Oh, I know that song.
That's where that comes from?"
To be honest with
you, not drumming
in the world's funkiest
group, not the book writing,
not being on late
night television--
my first love is records.
I've been listening
and analyzing
records since the age of five.
I've never shared the method
to my madness or my secrets
or my creative process
in DJing until right now.
In my MasterClass,
I will teach you
how to curate the
perfect playlist, how
to search for music, how to
figure out where it belongs.
And then, I want to teach
you how to utilize it,
by being an effective DJ.
So if I decide I need
an extra kick drum,
I can press when the kick
drum occurs, like right here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you have any
relationship with music,
this class is for you.
[BEATS DRUM RHYTHM]
That sort of rhythm
has not failed me yet.
It's rhythmic.
It's sexy.
It makes everyone want to get on
the dance floor and just party.
You can scratch.
You can mix.
You can cut.
You can beat juggle.
Take these tools and build
something of your own.
Loving music and learning
how to find it and appreciate
it and use it to
find effect, that's
what I want to teach you.
I'm Questlove, and
this is my MasterClass.